tous les quinze jours cette maman seront
à l'espace famille de vesoul un endroit
neutre pour maintenir un lien familial
dans un environnement sécurisé le
rendez-vous va durer une heure cette
mère va pouvoir retrouver sa fille de 15
ans qui vit dans un foyer
elle me manque beaucoup c'est normal ça
fait sept ans que les deux foyers
ça fait sept ans que je fais des visites
un magnétisé et je passe sur tribunal
tous les deux ans pour savoir si vous
regardez où on a redonné donc c'est très
dur
de l'autre côté du bâtiment par une
autre porte pour que personne ne se
croisent pour ne pas perturber les
enfants c'est un petit garçon de 4 ans
qui arrive il vit dans sa famille
d'accueil depuis deux ans et demi et
vient rencontrer ses parents tous les
trois mois un choix adapté pour le
préserver le protéger un quart d'heure
avant le rendez-vous il joue comme s'il
était dans sa maison l'occasion d'un
échange avec l'éducatrice tu as changé
d'école le palpitant
oui mais ça se passe bien mais tu t'es
fait des nouveaux copains c'est
important pour nous de savoir dans quel
état émotionnel se trouve l'enfant ya
des enfants qui sont peuvent être
stressé par ce moment là donc ne par le
temps des changes au travers du jeu avec
beaucoup de support du jeu c'est
important ça permet de les rassurer de
les sécuriser leur expliquer un petit
peu comment va se passer la visite en
2020 l'espace famille vesoul est géré
par l'association enfance bordeaux
accueille 900 visites médiatisées soit
deux fois plus qu'en 2018
dans ce lieu neutre où aucun éducateurs
net en lien avec la décision de
placement de l'enfant la bienveillance
c'est le maître mot
parce que on est dans la protection de
l'enfant bienveillance vis-à-vis de la
famille mais nos missions c'est de
protéger l'enfant est d'évaluer les
situations pour favoriser un parcours
sécurisé avec des prises en charge
individualisée
les réunions permettent de faire le
point sur l'accompagnement sur les
visites et la protection de l'enfance
est confiée aux conseils départementaux
nous accompagnons en 2000 enfants
dansaient sur ces deux mille enfants il
y en a à peu près 900 qui nous sont
confiés un c pour ca qu effectivement le
conseil départemental 1 le département
en 2018 a créé ces espaces familles pour
répondre à un droit fondamental de
l'enfant c'est celui d'être en lien avec
son histoire familiale
trois autres espaces familles ont été
créés dans le département ce qui
représente 3000 visites par an pour que
les enfants puissent maintenir un lien
avec leur histoire familiale